(jazz music)
- Okay, well, we
want a subtle queef
because we're coming in full
queef and want it to be like,
"Was that a fart,
or did she queef?"
And then later on in the episode
we find out that
she queefed, okay?
So, subtle, subtle,
subtle, subtle, subtle,
barely a queef type queef, okay?
All right, thank you.
Okay, bye bye.
- Dude, I'm so
pumped to be here.
- Hooray, I'm freaking
pumped that you're here, man.
- Thanks for letting
me come down.
I'm so pumped to do audience
warm-up for the shows, man.
- You murdered last season.
I especially love that joke
that you do about the dorms.
You can't be in
the dorms anymore
because everybody
jerks off together.
(laughing)
That's funny.
- Thanks for the
compliment, but that was
actually Pete Davidson.
- That wasn't you?
Well, you're here, right?
(laughing)
- Might as well do it.
- I think you were
probably good last year.
- I got to be honest, man,
I know New Orleans is a
dope place to do the show, but
it's not all that happening.
There's nobody on the streets.
It's pretty dead.
- Yeah, man.
- Ladies and gentlemen,
make it loud, New Orleans!
Adam Devine, give
it up, come on!
This is what it's all about.
- Cheers, man.
Oh!
Our first comic
coming to the stage is
so, so, so, so, so, so, so
(sniffs)
(laughter)
so funny!
- I'm looking for the
ultimate dick joke.
(laughter)
- A difficult place to do
cocaine is an air hockey table.
- Yeah, that's where
I like to take it.
(yelling)
- Why is your hair so poofy?
(pop music)
(yells)
- Hello!
Have you seen my friend, Adam?
Adam Devine.
- Oh, that's the
Workaholics guy!
(laughs)
- Help!
(distorted voices)
(pop music)
(yelling)
(exhales slowly)
(exhales sharply)
(pop music)
- I can't even walk into
Abercrombie and Fitch
without a guy going,
"Hi, are you lost?"
- Half orangutan,
half beast-man.
(yelling)
- Welcome to Adam
Devine's House Party!
- [Adam] It's pretty dead.
- Who are you looking at, man?
Look, I'm gonna go get
ready for the shows
and we'll kick it later, right?
I'll see you tonight?
Just text me when you're--
when you want to kick it.